in little garden city these park turns
into little Mexico small town big things
can happen in the heart of America a
community has come together for 90 years
to celebrate their heritage since 1926
members of Garden City Kansas have
rallied together for Mexico's
independence day to honor where they
came from and celebrate where they're
going Modelo stands with those who work
together back in the 1900s from the
people that were here it was very hard
for them to celebrate who they were back
then and that's why they brought the
Mexican fiesta so that they could let
people know that you know we have a
beautiful heritage a beautiful culture
and we want to show you what we have
because this is what's home now and we
don't want to forget where we come from
in Central America we got our
independence together that's why we
always are helping it doesn't matter
where we come from we are always giving
a hand
con nosotros para Hamas estamos Ron want
us in Harmonia que lo mejor que se puede
ser CA being importante Tara Harvey
Ezreal importante celebrar los para que
nuestros hijos
non-casual median del originated under
vienen para ESO es para ayudar a Raviv
en estas el arises de de la Stella lugar
donde venom o nosotros soy la presidenta
de la fiesta una plaza far away one of
the hardest moments in my life for me
was when we first moved to the United
States from Mexico because you leave
everything behind the pride of Wow I
came here not knowing a word of English
- I'm actually organizing a whole event
I am one of those people that actually
brings thousands and thousands of people
together that come from everywhere back
then they first started a small little
fiesta - what it is now it's just
amazing to see that it's important to
celebrate who you are not to be ashamed
of who you are but also to contribute to
your community and not be anybody but be
somebody